[Music]
the army I'll have no more to do with it
now
I want to be my own man
I started up a security firm my
apologies
Thursday night's always a bit not we
could mean Saturday it's gonna be a nice
day it's rather forward of you know I
saw the waiter for constant Pennywise
Thomas wait I have security means I
recently discovered criminal conspiracy
[Music]
you're a dancer aya I love dancing me
mr. pennyworth if they kill me they have
to kill you there will be no exchange
things go pear-shaped I'll do my best to
keep you alive
this great nation of ours does it move
itself we will take back this country so
coup d'etat as a rope if you have to use
French words for something I don't like
it
I don't like violence and I don't like
you mate
[Music]
take a fun a position in a good
household do write your Abama before you
40 hi everyone it's Charlie we got a
whole bunch of new Batman stuff to talk
about we have that Batman prequel show
pennyworth they just dropped a brand new
trailer and we got a whole bunch more
details for the Batman trilogy that Matt
Reeves is making with Robert Pattinson
so well break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos will do
a new round of that DC streaming service
giveaway
all you have to do to enter that is just
leave a comment about Batman on the
video the pennyworth trailer as you
could see is obviously them doing the
Batman characters in the style of say
like the Kingsmen series or maybe a
little bit James Bond because it's set
during the 1960's so they're trading on
a lot of those tropes but think of it as
Alfred Pennyworth becoming a member of
the Kingsmen and given his dialect it
seems like he's going more for Michael
Caine's Alfred than say like Michael
Goff's during the Michael Keaton era or
even more recently Jeremy Irons Alfred
during the Ben Affleck era a long time
ago I was in Burma my friends and I were
working for the local government they
were trying to buy the loyalty of tribal
leaders by bribing them with precious
stones but their caravans were being
raided in a forest north of Rangoon by a
bandit so we went looking for
disturbance
but in six months we never met anyone
who tried but like I said said during
the 1960's he's fresh out of the service
with the British Special Forces his two
army mates there obviously show up later
in the trailer so they're a much bigger
part of the series - and backing him up
but it's him sort of trying to make a
name for himself as a young
twentysomething he's about the same age
that Batman was when he became Batman
for the first time so you kind of see
how they're doing it mid 20s or so and
if they are really going with Christian
Bale's Batman sort of tracking those
particular characters then Bruce Wayne
would be born around 1975 so a little
while after the events of this series
even though it's a little hard to tell -
I'm guessing Thomas Wayne is somewhere
in his late 20s early 30s as well when
you go back and you watch a lot of the
Batman films and you watch Alfred they
do try to give the different versions of
Alfred some cool takedown moments but
some of them come off as being a little
more hardcore than others so I would say
just given how hardcore he looks during
this series fresh out of the military so
maybe he is a little bit more of a blend
between Michael Caine and Jeremy Irons
version of Alfred Wright lensing drone
mode
well Imaging is showing me two thousand
hostiles on the third floor why don't I
drop you off on the second I don't know
exactly how many episodes are supposed
to be but it seems like they pick up
with the plot pretty quickly like you
just have that quick montage at the
beginning as he gets out of the military
then starts trying to make his way in
more affluent society you see him in the
gentlemen's club he meets his love
interest her name is Esme
it seems like she gets kidnapped by the
villains pretty quickly the main villain
of the first season is named Lord
Hargreaves you probably recognize him
from a whole bunch of other stuff he's a
pretty notable character actor think of
him as being something like Mark
Strong's character from Robert Downey
jr. Sherlock movie his name was Lord
Blackwood but he was just using his
title his position of power within the
British government to try and take over
British society it's hard to glean
exactly what his plan is from his very
short evil guy monologue during the
trailer but because it's the 1960s that
was just a really huge cultural
revolution everywhere not just Great
Britain so maybe he's just trying to
take Great Britain back to a very
imperialist society much more
expansionist much more warlike they
trade a little on the comedy of his
early relationship with Thomas Wayne
like look I'll try to help you but if
this prisoner exchange winds up going
sideways and there's nothing I can do
about it the really interesting thing
that you notice about this though is
that if you're a Batman historian or
you've been reading Batman comics for a
long time or just following the movies
of the TV shows for a long time then you
know that Alfred is not married he has
no children so I don't want to make too
many predictions about what's gonna
happen to his love interest here but
whatever ends up happening it sounds
like it doesn't totally work out between
the two of them by the end of the series
because eventually he comes back to
America with Thomas Wayne and starts
working for him and then Bruce Wayne is
born and he sort of becomes a surrogate
father after he gets his big Batman
origin story in Crime Alley but they do
have a tag at the end of the trailer
winking at that where his family just
tells him play your cards right and you
could be someone's Butler by the age of
again just charting the timeline I
wouldn't be surprised if that is the age
at which he officially becomes Thomas
Waynes Butler so this sort of gives you
a timeline of this series so think of
him as being like late 20s early 30s
when this is picking up they've only
been a couple times in the comics that
they've dealt with Alfred's backstory
they always try to include Easter eggs
and things like that
his birthday is basically the date of
his first appearance during 1940
three they actually have a certificate
of it I think this is from the new 52
they also got into Alfred's back story
during Batman the Animated Series during
that episode the lion in the unicorn was
just resurfaces aspects of his time with
the British SAS when he has to help one
of his old friends
stop this big nuclear attack by one of
the Batman villains so pleased to make
your acquaintance mr. pennyworth if you
do exactly as I say you might live to
see tomorrow
the pennyworth show is dropping at the
end of July like the trailer said but
you can find it pretty much anywhere you
can buy shows ala carte like the Google
Play Store Amazon or iTunes but I don't
know exactly how many episodes is
supposed to be I think it's a relatively
limited series so I'm guessing between
eight to ten episodes getting into the
big news about the Batman trilogy so if
you didn't know Matt Reeves is now
planning a Batman trilogy that was the
deal that Robert Pattinson sign we knew
he was doing one movie but I think in
success everyone assumed that they would
eventually try to do a trilogy
regardless of whatever the story of the
first movie is going to be but we did
find out about who some of the villains
are and why it was Robert Pattinson that
the director went with big stuff first
though it finally seems like they're
actually gonna do Selina Kyle Catwoman
in a movie again even though we saw her
during the Dark Knight Rises I think
that this new version of the Batman
trilogy is meant to be a little bit more
comic book II than the ultra grounded
Christopher Nolan Dark Knight trilogy
you don't owe these people anymore
you've given them everything not
everything not yet they haven't said who
they're thinking about casting everybody
has their fan casting for the brand-new
version of Catwoman but I'm sure that
they'll announce it before the end of
the year the Riddler is also supposed to
be one of the main villains the penguin
then lesser villain but Firefly is also
supposed to be in the mix so I'm
guessing that the Riddler and the
penguin will really be the bigger bat
Selina Kyle Catwoman is a bit more of a
Batman ally than she is a villain at
times but charting the timeline they're
saying that this is happening post
Batman year one it's not his very first
year as Batman but it's still very early
in his career so sometime between the
events of Batman Begins in The Dark
Knight the way they treated Christian
Bale's Batman is that Dark Knight Rises
Batman was meant to be late 30s but they
made a big joke about the toll that
being Batman had put on his body so that
he basically had the body of an old man
even though he wasn't that old so Robert
Pattinson late 20s early 30s Batman
still very young because they're calling
it a world's greatest detective Batman
movie unless of a big action movie like
the later Batman movies have kind of
turned into I've been referring to it as
more of a mask of the phantasm type of
movie more of a neo noir detective story
like the classic Batman comics they
haven't given an official synopsis yet
but the Riddler is supposed to be
between the ages of 30 and 40 the
penguin is supposed to be between the
ages of 20 and 40 so just like a little
bit younger than the Riddler Catwoman
obviously is supposed to be about the
same age as Batman but Firefly is
supposed to be a little bit younger a
while ago we heard a rumor that the
penguin was supposed to be the major
villain of the movie but now it sounds
like the Riddler might wind up being the
big bad if he's going to be one of the
older more mature characters just a
little more in his element than the
younger Batman villains but at any time
I think about a really big Batman
trilogy in the Riddler being the main
villain behind it all all I can think
about is Batman hush but I don't think
that they're doing any hush stuff from
the comics because he's a completely
different character it's a completely
different type of story they sort of
takes him all the way back after a
lifetime of fighting criminals and this
is meant to be at the beginning of his
career there been all kinds of Robin
jokes and even though they are doing a
trilogy I don't know that there are any
plans
do any Robbin characters in any of the
films during the trilogy so I wouldn't
get your hopes up about that if you want
a lot of Robins stuff obviously there's
the Titans TV show in yes there are a
lot of rumors that they're actually
gonna shut down that DC Universe
streaming service and just take the
shows that they want to keep and put
those on the new Warner Brothers
streaming service next year but a lot of
that still conjecture and speculation so
it's still wide open to theory crafting
as far as we know they still plan to
keep Titans don't know what's going on
with Doom Patrol but pretty much any of
the other shows from the DC streaming
service except for maybe like Young
Justice might wind up getting cancelled
comic-con is coming up next month
but DC movies are skipping it so if they
drop any teasers for Wonder Woman 1984
I'll totally do a video about it but
that would be separate from the
comic-con stuff all the TV shows are
going and I do believe that there's
going to be a big Marvel panel because
they skipped last year because they
weren't quite ready to start promoting
Avengers end game yet but I'll start
doing some comic-con prep videos once we
learn about what all the big panels are
going to be there is a new Captain
America video that I'm working on for
later today too so just look out for
that as long as you have alerts enabled
for my channel you'll see the video when
I post it while you wait for everything
click here to learn about that brand new
Avengers in game Thor Loki spin-off TV
series and click here for that brand new
spider-man far from home trailer thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome we'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you